area 15 is now scary at 15 the art and
entertainment complex getting ready for
halloween we got rocky theaters joining
us live
with more on what they're doing hi rocky
welcome to scarier
15. i love that by the way scarier 15
that's a good play on words
um of course we are at area 15 that just
opened in september that's right and now
we're here
celebrating halloween i have a feeling
you guys did that on purpose yeah we
really wanted to be open for halloween
for sure because we love costumes
right i mean our aspiration is to have
costume parties all year round i love it
but you might as well start with
halloween you know
of course so what can people do this
weekend here at scarier 15. i hear it's
a family friendly
well we have two parties actually friday
night is scary at 15 and that's the
family friendly night
as you can see we're one of many rooms
that are just fantastic it'll be all
tricked out in halloween regalia
and lots of things to do lots of games
and fun and we've got lots of space here
at r15 as you can see
so it's going to be super safe and we're
going to follow all the protocols
everyone's got to wear a mask
so if you go online and you can get
tickets area15.com
it's gonna be a great weekend starting
four o'clock on friday okay and i feel
like the mask it's a nice little
halloween touch you know
it doesn't doesn't clash with your album
well there you go it's the one event
where a mass setter fits in
so it's not a problem so let's talk
about costumes because
obviously when you were when when we met
you did not have this one
but you felt no i just had to get a
little little touch i just need it i
feel like i need a little something so
later on in the show i better
give you a little makeover yeah okay so
what can people do with their costumes
here area 15. well there's going to be a
costume contest
and you know the whole idea is that we
want an immersive and experiential place
where people
participate so in a sense the costumes
whether it's this party or
or the future carnival on saturday night
the costumes are part of the event yeah
and
we really like to encourage and reward
creativity so if you come with a great
costume
trust me you'll be rewarded we love that
okay so now shall we introduce our
lovely
yes this is the spider sisters this is
the roving
piano mobile as you can see maybe you
can come forward a little bit
piano person she is and she should back
up
there she goes and we got our witch
magic and you know
the area 15 twist is the technology
piece you know there's a little bit
you know it's a modern feel but the
other thing i love about it is
look how much space we have exactly it
feels safe in here
we're being super safe with our mass and
having fun and you know
just sort of we can still have halloween
right so let's do it
well thank you so much chris chris by
the way is the director of content and
cool
stuff cool stuff so you're going to show
me more cool stuff right
we're going to show you some more stick
around we'll show you a few other things
before we're done this is just one of
many rooms here at air 15 yeah and this
is cool
all right we'll send it back to you